today the first lady announced her
formal agenda for the remainder of her
husband's time in office her b-best
initiative will focus on the well-being
of children both online and off tackling
teen opioid addiction suicide depression
and cyberbullying social media can be
both positively and negatively affect on
our children but too often it used in
negative ways when children learn
positive online behaviors early on
social media can be used in productive
ways and can affect positive change
I was fantastic but of course CNN
couldn't let the first lady have her
moment her husband has been known to be
named caller on Twitter and talk
aggressively on Twitter she addressed
this today in her speech with the
president sitting right there in the
front row now I think what she's saying
there is she's gonna do this in spite of
her husband's tweets maybe even because
of his behavior but let's focus on the
next generation these kids getting
bullied these kids facing really serious
issues in social media and going forward
with it no matter what he does yes she
was doing the whole thing as an attack
on her husband oh my god that's
ridiculous so let me get this straight
where Michelle Obama was celebrated by
the press and the celebrity set for her
let's move initiative Melania Trump
sefar
is treated skeptically before it even
began yesterday the Washington Post used
the occasion to speculate on the trumps
private relationship including their
sleeping arrangements or their or
whether they spend much time together at
all
the obscene rumor mongering continued at
today's White House briefing persistent
rumors
mrs. Trump does not live in this White
House and that she lives with her
parents somewhere in the suburbs what do
you make of those rooms I make the fact
that just when you think the Washington
Post can't get things that any more
wrong they do and that that is an
outrageous and ridiculous claim
now I remember Michelle Obama being
lauded for having different priorities
from her husband and for being a strong
independent woman but now that the
Trump's occupy the White House the press
takes every opportunity to define the
first lady only through what they view
as her husband's shortcomings she wakes
up in her own bedroom not not something
we normally see she doesn't eat with the
president and she really lives a life
similar to a lot of moms out there
President Trump and First Lady Melania
Trump are living essentially separate
lives within the White House is a
subject of a major Washington Post
report today the White House dismissed
it as tabloid gossip Trump goes for the
kiss and Saved by the hatch
that is more than a hat that is a
defensive perimeter gosh I wish we had a
funny late-night comedian now except for
a brief moment during the Lewinsky
affair
I don't recall this kind of granular
relationship coverage when Bill and
Hillary Clinton of course were in the
White House now if you want to know why
the media has trained its sights on the
first lady it's simple
she's a real asset to the President and
her popularity is soaring a new CNN poll
released today shows that milania's
favorability has gone from 47 percent in
January to 57 percent today
she's even jumped 15 percentage points
with Democrats imagine if we had a fair
press Melania Trump is also a
presidential spouse let's face it who
brushes off the celebrity culture and
avoids politics where Michelle wanted to
retool everything from nutrition
guidelines to school lunches and Hillary
wanted to remake all of health care
Melania just wants to help kids
well-being and also to raise her son now
that brings me to the media coverage of
Gina Haspel president Trump's nominee to
head the CIA if confirmed she'll be the
first woman to ever lead that
male-dominated agency Haspel is a
patriot she served the agency for 33
years most of it undercover so why won't
the left share her for breaking the
glass ceiling you know why because
killing off her nomination would hurt
Trump and because she carried out her
duty as instructed the White House is
standing by their CIA pick Gina Hass
fell despite reports she tried to back
out last week and despite her history
with waterboarding why support her given
the refusal to declassify critical
information about a tape that she
reportedly wiped her support for us
torture programs after 9/11 the fact
that she headed up a secret u.s.
detention camp in Thailand that somebody
was waterboarded there under her watch
didn't
well the truth is hospital oversaw
detention facility in Thailand in 2002
or a few al-qaeda operatives were
waterboarded but they make it sound like
she invented the interrogation technique
she did not it was authorized by George
W Bush and approved by his legal team
who briefed Congress on it there was
further static about Haspel being
involved as you heard with the
destruction of nearly a hundred tapes of
interrogations a newly declassified
review shows that she did not order the
tapes destruction her superior did and
with good reason
the anti-trump bullies almost drove
Haspel to withdraw her nomination but
she's holding firm good for her
those vilifying her are despicable I am
very disappointed in Rand Paul for
opposing her nomination as well but the
media have found one woman with a trump
connection to actually salute it's a
woman they literally roll out the red
carpet for porn star stormy Daniels
come on stormy stop making such a big
deal about this everyone knows it's just
an act
I work in adult films we're not really
known for our acting just tell me what
do you need for this to all go away a
resignation that her star is rising as a
result of all of this you know I saw
avenatti defending himself yesterday
saying this is all part of a maximum PR
campaign a maximum PR maximum pressure
campaign to get whatever stormy Daniels
once so you see stormy has been elevated
by the cultural political and now the
prosecutorial establishment now it's
amazing to watch the media disparage and
attack women of real substance while
they lured a woman who spends most of
her time hanging off a pole half or
completely naked a porn star who has
already signed a detailed letter by the
way stating that she had no affair with
Donald Trump
but now she's changed her story
to sell tickets to her strip act her
greatest accomplishment may be stripping
the Muller investigation of all
credibility so let the media applaud
there darling of the moment she's
actually a good representative of what
they've become but for America we're
gonna stick with substance and truly
independent women and that's the angle